The catalyticium, which is typically the contrast in MRI studies has gotten a lot of notoriety lately because
Chuck Norris, everybody knows who Chuck Norris is, well his wife was severely had a severe toxic reaction to the catalyticium and nearly died.
And so she is a survivor of catalyticium poisoning. I think they have a video on YouTube that you could search on YouTube and watch their video.
They are very outspoken about the dangers of catalyticium and the toxic reaction that a person could have with that.
But there's a lot of different symptoms that a person could have with with catalyticium or other CT contrast or the radiation toxicity.
That are even less you could say pervasive than you know extreme symptoms and these things can build up over time.
So how do we deal with this and how do we help a person overcome this when they have to do it MRI or they have to do a CT scan.
Well, you could detox it. So you could increase the the amount of detoxing that you're going to do.
First of all, this is a test you can measure catalyticium toxicity out if you are so inclined to run a test.
But if it's like chemical like catalyticium, you would work on you could use a key later.
You could use just detox support to help your detox pathways in the liver. That would be one thing that you could do.
But you could also do a homeopathy for catalyticium and I've done that for a number of patients and we could do a homeopath for the barium and some other things.
You know, barium is a heavy metal, but to do a homeopath for that the barium sulfite that they use at CT scan contrast can be extremely helpful as well.
So homeopathy helps pull that out. Keylation of EDTA or DMSA or modified citrus pectin some other mild keylators can help pull that out and supported the liver pathways
with like PUD1 and milk thistle and things like that can really help pull that out too.
So you could understand that. Remember the simple math of it, the amount of toxicity minus your abilities, body's ability, your liver's ability to get rid of that toxicity equals the amount of overall toxic load your body's going to be burdened with.
And if your liver is already burdened with trying to get rid of cancer cells or trying to get rid of other heavy metals that you're dealing with or you already know your genetics on your liver, you already have genetic pathway burdens that are going to be overstressed that you want to maybe rethink some of those things.
So there's sometimes you have to do it MRI you have to do a CT scan that's your kind of back to the quarter to really know what's going on.
But don't think that they are always perfectly safe. So just know that you can take some precautions to help pull that stuff out if you have if you're going to do one of those tests.